well classes are underway again at
Evergreen State College in Olympia
Washington it's a new year it's been
more than a year since students at that
College targeted professor Brett
Weinstein for harassment after he
refused to leave campus because he was
the wrong skin color if you think
Weinstein sounds like a civil rights
hero
you didn't go to Evergreen Weinstein had
to flee the campus after mobs targeted
him the faculty and the school's
President George bridges took the side
of the mob bridges Ward campus police to
stand down while violent leftists
occupied buildings and trashed the
campus we're not making this up it's on
tape it cost thousands of dollars in
damage remarkably bewilderingly a report
later commissioned by evergreen somehow
blamed Bret Weinstein for the crisis he
never returned to campus by the way he
doesn't work there anymore we covered
all this extensively on the show well
tonight a follow-up to that story
according to an evergreen professor
called Mike Parros the whole episode in
effect destroyed the school freshman
enrollment at Evergreen has fallen to
below 300 students this fall that's a
50% drop from just two years ago the
school has cancelled the plan dorm
renovation cut its budget and announced
layoffs unfortunately not of the
president if things keep moving in this
direction evergreen will close for once
a happy ending Brown University's
censoring a scientific study by one of
its own researchers because political
activists don't like it in a paper
published earlier this month a tenured
brown professor called lisa Lippmann
found that teenagers who say they want
to switch genders are often influenced
not surprisingly by friends and social
media like all young people are well the
study was solid enough to be picked up
by a reputable scientific journal in
fact Browns PR department sounded a
press release promoting the study but
then activists descended they were
offended by the conclusions of the study
not because the conclusions were wrong
no one even argued they were wrong but
because the conclusions were
ideologically inconvenient and therefore
unacceptable they demanded the data be
suppressed and remarkably Brown caved to
their demands the university yanked the
press release and apologized for sending
it in the first place this is not really
about Brown
this is what it looks like when reason
itself dies politics Trump's science
empirical conclusions are banned
acknowledging reality itself becomes a
criminal act
superstition reigns the Dark Ages
arrived this is what they told you the
Christian Right wanted to do they were
lying as soon as they took power they
did it themselves of course